some days everything's on edge even
upside down in ways where all you want
to do is to turn
around some say the light is at the end
of the tunnel there just hold them tight
and you will reach the life
but I just want to be
happy I just W to be
myself I just W to be
happy I just want to be
myself some days everything's on a
upside down
in ways where all you want to do is to
turn
around some say the light is at the end
of the tunnel there so just you hold
them tight and you will reach the light
ah I just want to be
happy I just want to be
myself ah ah ah I just want to be
myself I just to be happy I just to be
happy I just want to be
myself
I just W to be happy I just W to be
happy I just W to
be I just want to be
happy ah ah I just want to be
myself